heather good afternoon how in the world
are you i have primary custody of my
nine-year-old son
and he has an unhealthy relationship
with his dad
so i was wondering if it is ever morally
acceptable to terminate or limit
visitation between them
there are seasons there are moments
there are situations where
absolutely um you've got to
get between your son and somebody who's
hurting them or somebody's putting them
in a bad environment
and be the person who's responsible for
them right and so you terminate
whatever relationships you've got to
terminate in fact
um one of the chief mentors in my life
growing up learning counseling learning
psychology she was responsible for
terminating
parental rights in utero before kids
were born and so
yeah there's absolutely a place for that
but before we go there
back me up tell me about this
relationship with an unhealthy
relationship with your
between your son and his dad
um he's had a history with like opioid
addiction
um he'll go months without
you know seeing my son especially you
know in the first
like five six years of his life um
like six months at a time sometimes
my son will you know call him and call
him and call him and he won't
he won't answer or won't return his
calls that sucks
and i am i've been married
you know for five years
now and as he gets closer to my husband
my son's dad does not like that and
it's gotten to a point where he
will try telling lies you know about me
and about my husband
and my son will say you know i don't
believe that
and recently he started saying well if
you don't believe it then
you know i'm just going to let him adopt
you and i'm never going to see you again
and he did this over christmas and went
several weeks without you know he hung
up on my son after saying that and went
several weeks without
talking to him so my son was devastated
and
you know he believes him when he says
these things and
it's just does he know that his daddy's
sick
and i know there's a character immoral
here but i'm i'm trying to use a
language that a nine-year-old can
understand
does he know that daddy's sick yeah um
i try not to say and i don't want him to
think negatively about his dad sure you
know i don't want him to take that on
himself and listen
that's noble and i think that's that's
the right way to approach this
but there is a reality to it also right
so you can
say something like your daddy's a piece
of crap
and he's a loser and he's a drug addict
don't listen anything he says
you can say that and that's running his
daddy down
and i know in your heart that's what you
want to say right you want to just
sit down and look at your son and say
let me tell you about this dude the
other side of it
is you can tell your son daddy's sick
and sometimes the words and his thoughts
get jumbled up and they come out in ways
that
sound really mean he's not trying to
hurt you he would never hurt you
intentionally
but sometimes he says things that just
aren't right that just aren't true
because he's not doing well and that's a
totally different approach if you don't
say something like that you're right
your nine-year-old will begin
he's gonna internalize it anyway but
he's gonna have no fallback plan so he's
gotta have somebody in his life which
that's you
saying those things aren't true right
yeah and i have i've told him
you know he's just not he's not healthy
right now and
i said you know and sometimes when
people aren't healthy they don't really
know how to
show love in the way that they're
supposed to oh that's hey that's
beautiful heather you're doing great
you're doing great and we we're getting
into counseling
good well um right now my attorney is
suggesting that
you know that we at the very least
limit visitation i think
i think that's as wise as possible um it
doesn't sound like your
your son's dad is in any place to be a
parent
and if he is still a functioning addict
then your son's not
safe emotionally your son's not safe
psychologically your son's not safe
in person right um is is he
missing appointments is he keeping up
with child support is he doing those
things or no
oh no he he's been
consistently behind on child support
person's entire life
um our son has had a really extensive
medical
history resulting in like over 20
surgeries and just
oh man you know he has caused him to
miss really
important doctors and appointments just
out of spite he
decided to just keep him from me so hey
heather
you know the answer to this so why are
you calling
why are you not secure in your answer
and you're
what you know the right thing to do is
i just i didn't have i
i'm sorry no you're good i didn't have a
health i didn't have a relationship with
my dad and
my son's father also didn't i've just
tried
okay but listen this relationship listen
your son doesn't either
no he doesn't right and so trying to
force feed one together trying to duct
tape something together
is just hurting your son and i know that
you know that right
tell me about this tell me about your
your husband
he's uh he's been in my son's life since
he was about three
and it was very slow process
you know getting my son's just always
a mama's boy you know yeah of course i
was the only one that he ever really had
yeah and you're the only stable one
there that's exactly right so
but tell me about this guy is he a good
guy he's a good husband oh yeah
yes he is we have you know three other
boys now
and you know he's he's an awesome dad he
you know he loves my son as his own
he reached out you know wanting to adopt
him he just said you know
i would like to step up i'd like to
adopt him if
you don't want that i understand but if
you don't want that i need you to step
up
good for him dude you married well look
at you heather
well i mean it really caused a lot of
retaliation at first he agreed to it
he's like yes let's go through with this
adoption
we were going to start the process and
then
my son's dad ended up telling my son
about it and
i don't know if he gently did this or
how he went about it but
probably not because the guy the guy's
sick man the guy is sick
he's he is talking through
yeah he's talking through an opioid
filter and he's not
um he's not being the dad he's supposed
to be
and so here's the thing i'm gonna do
something i don't normally do i'm not
gonna give you an answer because
you already know what to do heather you
already know what to do what you've got
to do is
let the fantasy of your son and this
magical dad go
it's not going to exist it's not there
your son's dad has taken great gone
through
great lengths to make sure that he's not
well
he has made some significant choices in
his life to make sure that he's not
going to be connected to his son
and he's using his son as weapon and as
a weapon and as leverage
and he is tethered to this kid in a way
that the kid is drowning because
dad is underwater do i want to give up
on dad no but that's not something that
you can solve you're in a new marriage
in a new relationship
and dad has chosen to not be a father
and the the the
fairy tale of this particular story
heather you married a stud you married a
rock star
who loves you and who had enough courage
to go to this boy's um i'm not going to
call him a dad go to his boy's father
and say hey i'm about to step up and do
the right thing here unless you do
and then you think the bait you know
your son's dad was like
your son's father was like okay go ahead
man
ridiculous dude you are in a great
situation
you actually have an opportunity for
your son to have a father
have a dad right have somebody who's
connected to him raises him as his own
four boys running a muck in your house
and you can untether yourself from this
loser once and for all
my hope my deepest hope is this dude
gets connected to a rehab program
gets his head screwed on straight does
the hard hard work
of going to a group for year after year
and getting sober
and getting clean and then doing the
hard
humble groveling on his face work of
coming back into your son's life and
saying
i screwed up i sucked i used you
son as leverage and a tool to hurt your
mom because i was sick and i'm sorry
and that's years away and that's not
going to happen now it's not going to
happen tomorrow
what can happen now what can happen
tomorrow is
you knew what the right thing is you've
got experts you've got professionals in
your life saying
whoa we got to step in you know that's
the right thing to do
and you got an awesome guy ready to be a
dad
to your little boy so thank you so much
for the call
you are doing all the right things
heather
you just gotta kill the fantasy let the
fantasy be absolutely gone let it
poof like a vapor like frozen two i
don't even know how frozen two ended but
if it ended like a vapor i want you to
end it like that otherwise
um go for it you're in the right place
doing the right thing good for you
heather